paradojas de los que padecen el trio extremo
estos migrantes y stano kados en uno
búsqueda masiva de la frontera de bielorrusia con
polonia y el bernés el presidente
el bielorruso alexander lukashenko visitó
el campamento fue express parisino
público y la frontera de las menciones déco
crisis humanitaria una segunda crisis de esquí
la unión europea fue y deliberadamente
semi a dapor lukashenko endre tomado alia
el penal schelb lo que impulso con el
represión del gobierno contra
demostración sin tablero y la
democracia en el pais polonia letonia e
lituania que lleva las peores partes
de la crisis front brawl ande explicó
miller de los soldados de la policía me disparan
retrasos y bajas migrantes crutzen en sia
en el territorio lukashenko del cual
migrantes y en el campamento que no son serios
también alimentado puedo hablar de rick
irsea tanto la union europea sicher a
evolucionar en casa y lo mandado quiero
presión apolloni tiene varios para
lowes migrantes passaro mine
enfoque que letra de la nueva alla
La nación polaca no necesita a Moisés
investigación de implantes de amianto de guerra
que en la base alemania giovanna vela
rusnya polonia locura banal que lo
spasari y el problema se resolverá es el
El primer ministro polaco estaba de visita
capital europea si esta semana y en
busque apoyo para una respuesta
contundente en minsk la union europea tiene
otorgada nueva sanción escribe beria
adoptar para hacer ping cierra diciembre es el
blog acusó a lukashenko de creer
la crisis distribuyendo vista dos
Bielorrusia y Liev Oriente Medio fueron a
los migrantes bielorrusia minsk ha
comentado y evolucionará algunos migrantes
a sus respectivas páginas incluyendo
skiantos de personas a irak a un che
varsovia dijo que es un
cambio de táctica masche de una señal
de autenticación de escalada